space watchers expect to be busy all
weekend trying to detect
where a wayward chinese rocket will fall
to the earth in the next few days
now china's foreign ministry predicts it
will cause no harm
other agencies they are not so sure
raimi innocencio reports on the orbital
mission
that went way off course
china's space station ambitions blasted
off last week
a massive rocket called the long march
5b
powering the station's core module into
orbit
where future astronauts will live the
20-ton rocket was
not supposed to fly that high but it did
and now it's out of control bill harwood
is cbs news space analyst
so what went wrong the chinese don't
build their rockets so that you can
restart the engines and deliberately
drive them out of orbit
whenever you want it's coming down on
its own it apparently is tumbling
hurtling around earth at 17 000 miles an
hour
that's about 83 football fields each
second
and it's orbiting us north to south at a
tilt
of about 41 degrees below its path is
mostly water but still
a lot of land much of the us from
chicago
southwards south america australia
asia europe and africa
that means it could pretty much land
crash really
uh almost anywhere on the planet right
that's right and the odds are
it won't hit anybody or any populated uh
in area
but it could the pentagon does have the
strike capability to shoot the rocket
down but they've said
they won't if you hit a spacecraft with
a weapon and break it up
instead of one big piece you've got
thousands and thousands of pieces
that threatens the thousands of other
satellites in orbit and could string a
wider swath of debris
across the earth for cbs this morning
raimi in asensio
hong kong feel comforted now
i keep remembering what i learned in
fifth grade seventy percent of the earth
is water water that's the totally lands
in the water that means thirty percent
ain't
i know and i look you know it's probably
not going to but it could
yeah well no could yeah just keep
looking up
get out your helmets people